Welcome back everyone this will be my full star
wars book of bova fett episode 6 video probably
the best episode so far so much happened
there's so many easter eggs to break down
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes there'll
be more teasers for the mandalorian season 3
in the book of boba fett finale next week too
and the obi-wan kenobi series which i'll also be
doing episodes for that'll be the next big star
wars series and we'll get episodes for that
this spring you won't have to wait that long
careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet there are so many things that we
have to talk about starting with the episode title
from the desert comes a stranger which is mostly
meant to be a reference to cad bane showing up in
the live-action series almost killing cobb vanth
a classic western gunslinger standoff very similar
to the one that he had with boba fett in the lost
clone wars episodes which you may have seen if
you're a big clone wars fan that was the episode
where they showed you how boba fett got the dent
in his helmet in a gunslinger standoff moment
where cad bane shot him they also referenced that
at the end of the episode when he tells cobb vanth
you should have kept the armor meaning that he
actually knows that he had boba fett's armor just
in service of setting up a big boba fett versus
cobb vanth gunslinger standoff in the finale
dave filoni wrote this episode because he created
the cad bane character he also created the ahsoka
character he wrote and directed the ahsoka episode
during the mandalorian season 2 he tends to work
more heavily on the episodes involving characters
that he created if you didn't watch the clone
wars episodes you have no idea who cad bane is he
was the most fearsome bounty hunter in the galaxy
before boba fett came up he is the person who
trained boba fett how to be a bounty hunter there
were a lot of references that cad bane had when he
was talking to cobb vanth warning him about boba
fett that were meant to be references to his time
with boba fett in the clone wars when the empire
took over the galaxy cad bane was one of the few
old school clone wars characters who survived the
imperial era during the original trilogy he pulled
jobs for the empire but they never really had any
canonical stories about his adventures during
the events of the original trilogy until now
but the actual opening scene is cobb vance
versus the pyke syndicate when they come
into most pelgo territory where he's stationed
it's the same area where mando found him during
the mandalorian season 2 same town we go back
to there's a lot of references in the episode
to the mandalorian season 2 episode 1 in all the
scenes with cobb vance in this area when the pykes
claim that they're going back to mos eisley and
then cobb vance says pretty much anything goes
and most honestly it's just them referencing
all the different major cities on tatooine
we were also just in most iceland in last week's
episode they want to let you know that the pykes
in the kid is basically taking over the entire
planet they have a classic gunslinger standoff he
kills all but one then takes the box of spice even
though he makes all the references to retiring he
just kicks it over letting it blow away to
remind you that he is a good character like
he's not going to take a bribe or something like
this he's not going to keep it for himself then
they pay off the scene of mando talking about
making the stopover to see his little friend in
last week's episode taking his modified naboo n1
starfighter to the planet where luke skywalker is
training grogu as a jedi to give him his little
mandalorian baskar armor most of us theorize
that it would be a chainmail shirt because of
those tiny little ringlets but the whole idea
mando talks about the armor being his by rights
talking about grogu is a mandalorian foundling
my theory during the mandalorian season one is
that the title of the series was also meant to be
a reference to grogu like the mandalorian wasn't
just meant to reference din jaron's character
it was also meant to reference grogu's character
because grogu is also becoming a mandalorian r2d2
greets him when he lands and he also says the name
skywalker for the first time he didn't use luke
skywalker's name during the mandalorian season 2
finale also really surprised that they physically
brought luke skywalker back now remember it's a
combination of them deep faking this actor's face
the actor who played the new republic x-wing pilot
in this episode is the person who is the double
for luke skywalker during the mandalorian season
2. they just did the exact same thing they did
during the finale for this episode so mark hamill
came back again and recorded a new dialogue for
the episode and i do feel like the visual effects
for luke skywalker looked better than the deep
fake that they did during the mandalorian season
too like whatever their technology they're using
has gotten a little bit better they confirmed that
this is the planet where luke skywalker builds his
jedi temple that was later destroyed by kylo ren
about 25 years in the future is less than 30 years
so it's like 25 30 years almost but the funny
thing is they still have not revealed which planet
it is they haven't named it yet so we still don't
know where this planet actually is we see a bunch
of spider droids constructing the actual jedi
temple and the whole idea here is ahsoka explains
later is that grogu would be the first student
at the jedi temple but i think they're clearly
foreshadowing him leaving his jedi training just
like luke skywalker left yoda's jedi training
there are a lot of parallels in this episode
during scenes for the scenes of luke skywalker
training with yoda and empire strikes back some
of them are a little more obvious than others
but remember what happened to luke during empire
strikes back he left to go help his friends so
grogu is also probably going to leave to go help
mando and that'll probably explain why he survives
kylo ren's quote unquote purge there are a couple
references to purges during this episode like you
have the order 66 purges they flash back to you
also have the mandalorians great purge that we
just saw in last week's episode but then they also
have kylo ren's purge that will be happening in 25
years here there's also some clever references
to that in some of ahsoka's dialogue too about
grogu being safe on this planet like no we've seen
the new star wars movies there's no way that he's
safe on this planet they reveal the reason why
r2d2 shuts off and the spider droids construct
him this makeshift bench is because they knew
that he might show up and they just instructed
r2d2 in the spider droids to do this should
mando ever show up but it's all just in service
of maintaining the integrity of grogu's jedi
training like they don't want him to see mando
because that'd make it harder for him to leave
his attachments behind even though very clearly
he's going to be going back to mando by the end of
the episode this is meant to be a parallel for the
choices that mando will have to make eventually
too like does he become a full mandalorian again
and lead the mandalorian people using the
darksaber does he become the new man to lore
or does he choose to continue his fatherly
relationship with grogu like both mando and grogu
have a lightsaber of their own that represents
one path and then another path that involves
them continuing to be together i think that's
another reason why they brought ahsoka back for
this episode there are a couple reasons why they
brought her back that i'll get into eventually
but one of the reasons was to foreshadow mando and
grogu choosing their own path because ahsoka is
another person who left the jedi training left
the jedi temple even though she comes back to
visit luke skywalker here at his jedi temple she's
not coming back to do more jedi training ahsoka is
a person who chose her own path and think about
how powerful she is so grogu even though he will
eventually leave the jedi training probably could
still go on to become a very powerful force user
and remember he's gonna live for like 900 years
so even if mando lives to like the age of 90
that's still a drop in the bucket for grogu groga
could always go back and pick up his jedi training
after mando dies of old age then we actually get
to see luke skywalker training grogu and they have
that funny scene with him playing with the frogs
forced levitating them it's meant to be a callback
to when he and mando were on sorghum and he tried
to eat one of the frogs with the little kids
this time he just tries to eat one using the force
when luke skywalker levitates all the frogs in the
pond it's meant to be a reference to yoda lifting
his x-wing out of the swamp on dagobah grogo
seems amazed the same way that luke skywalker
couldn't believe how yoda could do that that's
why right after this luke tells him all about yoda
i love the way that instead of picking him up and
carrying him or walking super slow so that grogu's
tiny little legs could keep up he just picks him
up with the force and sets him down every once in
a while when luke skywalker starts speaking about
yoda they start playing yoda's theme music
from empire strikes back they also played a
couple more times during the episode when they're
training and then again at the end of the episode
when he offers him yoda's lightsaber i know a
lot of you would be like wait a minute where did
he get yoda's lightsaber from i thought that he
lost it on coruscant after his fight with emperor
palpatine the canon story is that yoda recovered
the lightsaber before he went to dagobah and then
just kept it in a box in his hut on dagobah so
i think the idea is that luke skywalker took his
lightsaber with him after yoda died in return
of the jedi and he just kept it with him this
whole time there's also a bit of a funny moment
where they imply that yoda was the only one of his
kind who spoke in that backwards manner he would
speak in riddles have you heard anyone talk like
that back home because the way grogu reacts to it
like wait what i don't remember anybody talking
like that but also they explain grogu barely
remembers his life at the jedi temple on coruscant
until luke skywalker uses the force to help pull
his memories out if you don't remember ahsoka
basically told us during the mandalorian season
2 that grogu had buried his memories deep in his
own mind as a way of dealing with the trauma
of order 66 and the purge which they actually
do show us and it's meant to be a parallel for
the flashbacks to the mandalorians great purge
we actually see grogu's memories of order 66 and
obviously it's a very small contained scene they
don't show us anakin skywalker slicing through a
bunch of younglings but we do see clone troopers
killing the jedi librarian and two other jedi
i'm not sure which other jedi these two are but
i think this is meant to confirm that the jedi
librarian was the jedi who saved him they teased
this during the mandalorian season 2 when ahsoka
was talking about him being saved by a jedi but
grogu couldn't remember who it was he gives grogu
the same yoda size matters not speech because
look at him he's tiny i can't it's too big his
eyes matter smacked look at me just mean by my
size do you these brief training sessions along
with him helping grogu remember his original jedi
training back at the temple i think is setting up
some boss level jedi moves that he'll have in the
finale and during the mandalorian season 3. like
each new season grogu does something even crazier
even bigger i think they're just setting up
even bigger stuff in the future love the way
that ahsoka surprises bando napping when she says
she's an old friend of the family that's because
she was anakin skywalker's padawan she also makes
a couple references to anakin skywalker later in
the episode too telling luke you're just like your
father basically just to explain her timeline and
how much she knew luke and leia she would have
found out about anakin and padme's twins during
their fight against the empire in the fall of the
emperor return of the jedi but her coming to luke
skywalker's jedi temple would have been the first
canonical time she actually met luke skywalker in
person i'm assuming that at some point during
this time period she'll also meet leia if she
hasn't already but like at the end of the episode
luke says will i ever see you again she says maybe
that's basically meant to be a yes and also let
you know that there'll be more luke skywalker
cameo scenes like this at some point in the
future when ahsoka is talking to the mandalorian
about not wanting to mess with grogu's head by
allowing him to see him in person to actually meet
you remember she has more reason than anyone to
want to avoid any attachment conflicts because
she's still got that ptsd from what happened with
anakin skywalker turning into darth vader going
to the dark side she referenced that during the
mandalorian season too i've seen what attachments
like this can do to a jedi and like i said
she also foreshadows grogu leaving because she
says this is the safest place for him with luke
skywalker on this planet but we know she's wrong
because kylo ren's going to destroy the temple in
around 25 years so they really want to beat you in
the face with the idea that grogu needs to leave
this planet but ahsoka will understand eventually
remember she left the jedi temple and that's how
she survived order 66 so grogu leaving is the
exact same situation he survives kylo ren's purge
later on because he's not there when mando starts
calling grogu a mandalorian foundling saying that
the besgar armor is his by rights foundlings are
what they call the children that they rescue and
then take into their culture and eventually each
of the children when they take the mandalorian
creed get their first set a mandalorian armor
that's what he means when he says the tiny
besgar armor chainmail is grogus by rights and
it's not until grogu sees the mandalorians naboo
starfighter taking off that he senses his presence
the reason why he didn't sense it before this is
because he just hasn't gained enough skill in the
force he's still very powerful right now but he
wields the force kind of like a blunt instrument
eventually he'll learn to wield it more like a
scalpel and he'll be able to sense things over
much larger distances you also probably recognize
luke skywalker's backpack here that he's carrying
around in this is luke's original backpack that
he had with him during empire strikes back when
he was training with yoda carrying yoda around in
the backpack i guess he just kept it within this
whole time through everything and it just survived
this long then they have their version of a jedi
training montage mirroring a lot of the scenes
of luke skywalker's training with yoda in empire
strikes back and the thing to remember here is
that all the different skills that grogu shows off
they'll probably pay off and have him do in either
the finale or during the mandalorian season 3.
he learns to force jump which is a very common
jedi technique when he starts running through
the bamboo forest in the jungle with him in the
pouch it's a parallel for luke running around on
dagobah with yoda in the backpack he also trains
grogu to levitate and balance the way that he did
with yoda balancing on his foot he even gives
him some rudimentary lightsaber training while
levitating himself then he pulls out the same
type of training remote that obi-wan kenobi
used to train him during a new hope i think him
telling grogu to get back up always get back up
is very important to remember too they'll probably
pay that off during a future fight that grogu has
all these skills all these lessons they'll pay off
in future episodes when groku starts force jumping
and flipping all over the place to avoid the drone
it's meant to be a parallel for yoda fighting
count dooku and attack of the clones jumping all
over the place you just imagine grogu having a
tiny little lightsaber in his hand while this is
happening then when luke says that this is more
like grogu remembering more than him teaching he's
talking about all the years of training gurugu had
at the jedi temple before order 66 they explained
during the mandalorian season too that grogu
suppressed all of his jedi abilities all of his
training and he started to forget the teachings
over time but that was mostly a defense mechanism
to prevent darth vader and the jedi inquisitors
from being able to sense him through the force
ahsoka tells luke skywalker that he's just like
his father anakin skywalker when he's talking
about grogu not having his heart in training
giving him these sage advice during the clone
wars episodes anakin skywalker would often speak
to ahsoka like that she then leaves the planet
saying that she might she might see him again
and i think that's meant to be a teaser for the
ahsoka series those episodes will start releasing
next year after the mandalorian season 3 and cover
a lot of the grand admiral thrawn storyline it'll
be bringing back a lot of the star wars rebels
characters too but i think the idea is that
ahsoka will also probably come back to cameo
scene during the mandalorian season 3. mando
goes back to jabba's palace to meet up with boba
fett and his small army that he's assembled they
explained their battle plan for fighting the pyke
syndicate you notice they still have the major
dormo with them they have them in chains these are
just giving them advice on how to fight the pykes
black krsantann joined up with boba fett a couple
episodes ago so he's been there for a little while
then mando goes back to cobb vance to try and get
help from the people of most peligo to be their
foot soldiers he passes the jawa sand crawler they
revealed that they joined the crate dragon's skull
after they killed it in the mandalorian season
2 episode 1. i guess the clan of tusken raiders
didn't care about the skull they just wanted the
pearl we also found out they're using part of the
rib cage of the crate dragon inside the bar just
to decorate it and the funny thing here you all
probably picked up on is when cobb vance mentions
grogu like oh it's so sad that you lost your
little friend there we both lost something that
we love talking about losing boba fett's armor the
way they framed the shot on the naboo starfighter
they make sure to focus on the tiny little grogu
size pod in the middle that's just another
teaser for grogu leaving luke's jedi temple
and flying around with mando during the finale
yes i do think they will eventually get a bigger
ship maybe at the end of the finale or maybe at
the beginning of the mandalorian season three
i don't think he's gonna fly around in this
tiny naboo starfighter forever at a certain
point it just becomes impractical then a lot of
the conversation that mando has with cobb vanth
sets up the big standoff that he has with cad
bane like cobb vanth says as long as i'm here
the spice trade isn't going to be a problem in
mando tells him you never back down from bullies
they also brought back the weekway bartender
played by w earl brown the actor from deadwood
and justified also two tv series that are
westerns that timothy oliphant starred in
because there's this very western vibe going on
here like you have classic gunslinger moments
he tells them they change the name of the town to
freetown and to cobb vance credit even though he
resists he does finally offer the town's help
like okay round everybody up that can fight
even though cad bane comes and complicates
things he implies that he's been hired by
the pyke syndicate to help deal with boba fett
to help them take over the planet when he tries
to warn cobb vance about boba fett calling him a
cold blooded killer is a reference to his history
in all of his episodes with boba fett during the
clone wars also another callback to the gunslinger
standoff that he had with boba fett where he gave
boba fett the dent in his helmet when he says you
should have never given up that armor is also
a reference to that same lost episode because
the armor saved boba fett's life because cad bane
gave him a head shot but if it wasn't clear covant
is still alive that's why everyone's yelling
about med packs and stims standing over his body
and why they didn't have cad bane shoot him
multiple times and why it's a body shot instead
of going for the head everyone post all your
thanos memes you should have gone for the head
this whole cad bane sequence is really just to
set up boba fett versus cad bane in a rematch
in the finale where boba fett will probably kill
him just early prediction there's a lot of history
between the two of them so i'd recommend if you
haven't seen them go back and watch those clone
wars episodes with boba fett and cad bane then the
whole idea here with the group of pyke syndicate
destroying garso whips cantina with the cam tono
bomb it's just meant to galvanize the people of
mos espa against the pykes like they really really
want everyone on tatooine all over the place
to hate the pyke syndicate you could also think
of this bombing as a reference to the untouchables
with the briefcase bomb like wait you forgot your
briefcase then boom blows the bar up also the
droid server here kind of sounded like anthony
daniels so it might have been a stealth cameo
scene like mark campbell does stealth cameo scenes
as other characters that are not luke skywalker
then during the ending scene like i said luke
skywalker gives grogu his choice the best guard
chainmail armor or yoda's original lightsaber
but as i've said many times in the video
clearly foreshadowing the grogu is going to choose
to go back to the mandalorian and they'll explain
how he survived kylo ren's purge in the future and
instead of yoda's lightsaber maybe they'll have
him create his own lightsaber eventually because
there is official art that the star wars people
release of him constructing a yellow lightsaber
a lot of you've also asked if he would just use
the darksaber like groga could force levitate the
darksaber and wield it that way his little tiny
hand isn't big enough to reach around the hilt
though so he couldn't use like a traditional
lightsaber and him leaving with his training
incomplete mostly meant to be a callback to luke
skywalker leaving his training with yoda during
empire strikes back to help han solo in leia a
cloud city but also ahsoka who was in the episode
left the jedi temple left her training before it
was complete either way episode 7 next week is the
finale the last episode they'll have a bunch of
scenes setting up the mandalorian season 3 maybe
like a full teaser trailer but we also might get
a full obi-wan kenobi trailer so whatever they
wind up releasing of course we'll do videos for it
if you saw any other big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments everyone click
here for all my book of boba fett episode videos
mandalorian easter eggs and click here to learn
about that brand new marvel doctor strange 2 iron
man announcement thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and may the force be with you!